Sean Connery is basically a living
legend in Hollywood but it's been
decades since he last took a significant
role in a movie so what drove such a
talented and respected actor out of the
spotlight and could anything lure him
back
Connery hasn't appeared in a film since
2003 when he starred in the League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen his absence was
noted over the following years but
Connery kept quiet about his future
plans which left fans wondering whether
he would ever return to acting finally
in 2006 he said that he had officially
retired confirming his status after
receiving a Lifetime Achievement Award
from the American Film Institute in a
2007 interview with heat vision he
reaffirmed that he truly was done with
acting at this point it could be argued
that Connery doesn't have anything left
to accomplish in Hollywood he had
already established a long lasting
legacy and retiring when he was ready
rather than continuing to make films
solely for the money
is the decision worthy of respect after
all what could really top being James
Bond and Indiana Jones's dad what did
you find me
[Music]
ilumination Connery never explicitly
stated the reason for retirement but it
seems that a number of different factors
led him to decide it was finally time to
hang up his hat the League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen was panned by
critics man rather than picking up one
more role to end his career on a better
note he chose to follow his initial
instinct and walk away Connery was very
frustrated with this experience working
with director Stephen Norrington on
gentlemen even saying that Norrington
should have been quote locked up for
insanity Connery has since explained
that he did his best with the role but
knew that the entire production was
going off the rails and that critics and
audiences alike probably wouldn't be too
pleased he even claimed that he got
heavily involved in editing in an
attempt to salvage the end result and
while his efforts may have helped
somewhat - the film was still considered
a massive flop Connery walked away and
has never looked back
having struggled on the set of the
League of Extraordinary Gentlemen and
taking a subsequent decision to retire
one offer did Pete Connery's interest in
returning to the big screen he was
contacted by Steven Spielberg who spoke
with him about reprise in his role as
Indiana Jones's father dr. Henry Jones
from Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade
hechos Connery seriously considered
Spielberg's request for him to appear in
Indiana Jones in the Crystal Skull but
in the end he decided it just wasn't
worth coming out of retirement and
although he did hold some creative
differences with Spielberg as far as the
character and the proposed direction of
the plot were concerned more importantly
he didn't want to deal with the
pressures of acting again in a statement
on his website Connery wrote if anything
could have pulled me out of retirement
it would have been in Indiana Jones film
but in the end retirement is just too
much fun there was actually a time when
it seemed like Connery might stage a
career comeback and he even implied that
it wouldn't be totally impossible for a
director to lure him back in front of
the camera
however he has made it clear that doing
so would require a serious paycheck
creeping to the Scottsman that he would
almost need a mafia-like
offer I couldn't refuse to do another
movie but now it appears that this
window has closed for good
according to Connery's longtime friend
and fellow actor Michael Caine Connery
has shut the door on any potential
offers in 2011 Kane told The Telegraph
he won't make another film now I just
asked him he said no I'll never do it
it seems that Connery could not be more
clear about the fact that his acting
career is long over
despite the sizeable paycheck that he
could probably wrangle from the right
production although some of his fans may
hold out hope that there could be
another film on the horizon
it looks like the chances are slim to
none he may not be interested in going
before the cameras but Sean Connery has
made a small exception to his retirement
from acting voice work in fact you can
hear his distinctive voice on a handful
of projects that have been released
since his retirement in 2003 in 2005
Connery returned to the world of James
Bond when he provided voice work for the
videogame version of his 1963 film From
Russia With Love executive producer Glen
Schofield said Connery agreed to the
part for two reasons
because From Russia With Love was his
favorite Bond film and because his
grandchildren loved video games
Connery also voiced the title character
in the animated short sir Billy the
Vettes which was later expanded into a
feature film and officially released in
2012 he also served as the executive
producer for the extended version but
hasn't been back to the micro screen
project since so how does Sean Connery
spend his days now that he's retired
well he has all the time in the world to
spend indulging in his love of golf
which originated when he was filming the
1964 Bond movie Goldfinger
that's his origin of all I know Palmer
doesn't how do you know I'm standing on
it while practicing his golf game for
the film Connery got hooked on the sport
and his autobiography being a Scot he
wrote I began to see golf is a metaphor
for living poor in golf you are
basically on your own competing against
herself and always trying to do better
today Connery's home in the Bahamas is
actually located on a golf course and
according to his son Jason Connery he
can still hit a hole-in-one so while you
won't find Connery walking the red
carpet any time soon you might just
catch him playing golf in paradise it's
definitely not a bad way to spend
retirement check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stars are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]